just been convicted for a manslaughter
through gross negligence so there's
clearly a disparity between terrorists
and the security forces that served in
Northern Ireland
totally unacceptable and something that
we've been saying all along throughout
the Legacy process it's a disgrace and
should never have happened
and that's all I've got to say on the
matter thank you very much
well that's of course live to Belfast
Crown Court Skies David blevant is there
for us and David David Holden the is the
first veteran to be found guilty of a
historical offense in Northern Ireland
sentenced today how significant a moment
is this
well you just heard from Paul Young who
speaks for former British soldiers who
served on the streets of Northern
Ireland during the troubles
understandably they think a three-year
sentence for manslaughter is Harsh
despite the fact that it's been
suspended for three years meaning David
Holden is not going to be sent to prison
I expect Aiden mcanaski the victim his
family will completely disagree with
that we expect to hear from them also
within the next half an hour and that's
because 53 year old David Holden was
found guilty of the gross negligent
manslaughter of 23 year old Aidan
mcanesby who was shot dead back in 1988
while he was a person of interest to the
security forces in other words a suspect
he was unarmed when he was shot in the
back after walking through a military
checkpoint to Dr McCloy in County Tyrone
on his way home from a Gaelic football
match David Holden a former Grenadier
Guardsman was 18 years old at the time
and he did admit firing the Fatal shot
although he said he had done so
accidentally because his hands were wet
from cleaning the walls of the singer at
the time in giving his judgment a few
weeks ago Mr Justice O'Hara described
that as a deliberately false a kind so
he's taken some time to think about what
sentence to impose after finding him
guilty he did list some of the
mitigating factors brought by the
defense they said he was just 18 years
old at the time that he'd been convicted
of manslaughter and not murder and that
while he was grossly negligent there
were others who were equally culpable
who were not before the court and that
the Army itself might be negligent the
sentencing hearing also heard some
harrowing Victim Impact statements one
of them from the family recalling how
their late mother used to walk every
evening from her home to the spot at
that military checkpoint where her son
was shot dead reciting the rosary and
they talked about the fact that this is
not a legacy case for them it is an
everyday occurrence for them still
trying to come to terms with what
happened to their brother 35 years ago
but ultimately Mr Justice O'Hara despite
the fact that he'd weighed up a number
of a number of similar cases that came
to the conclusion that because David
Holden had no previous conviction and
had as he said made a positive
contribution to society in his career
since he was imposing a three-year
sentence but suspending it for three
years and therefore he has escaped a
custodial sentence because of
controversial Legacy
legislation currently making its way
through Parliament which would
effectively bring to an end this type of
prosecution relating to historical
offenses in Northern Ireland he may well
turn out to be both the first and the
last to be convicted of a historical
offense during the troubles since the
Good Friday agreement in 1998.